Okay. So now, we've discussed basic browsers, HTML, HTTP, which is
how the browsers talk to the servers. And now, we're finally
going to get to servers, which is what most of this course
is going to be about. How to run programs on servers. The
purpose of a server is to respond to HTTP requests. We've
drawn this picture a couple of times now. This is you.
This is your computer running your browser. And these are our
servers. These little pink boxes. Your browser is speaking HTTP to these
servers to request documents. There are two
main classifications for the type of responses the
server will do. They are called static
and dynamic. Content is considered static if it's
a pre-written file that the server just
returns. An example would be an image. Most
images are static requests. All the server does
is says, it looks up the image off
of its hard disk or off of its cache, and just
sends it over the wire using HTTP. More interesting requests are dynamic
requests. These are requests where the response is built on the
fly by a program that's running. Just about all of the content
online these days is dynamic. That didn't always use to be
the case. When the web was first invented in the early 90s,
almost all of the content online was static. They were just
files. People would edit the files, put them on their servers, and
they all linked to one another, but that was
that. These days, almost every website including Udacity, Reddit
and Hipmunk, the two websites that I worked on.
Wikipedia, Facebook. All of those pages, almost 100% of
them are built dynamically on the fly by programs
called web applications. And a web application is just
a program that generates content. And that is what
we're going to learn how to build in this course.
So we've spent all of this time getting to
this description of what a web application does. Which
is, it lives on a web server, it speaks
HTTP, and it generates content that your browser requests.